do you cut people off out of revenge
gang gang honk honk there you go ginger
you're on the hot seat
straight up honest about that i've
wanted to
you know and there's times when it's
like you know i'm gonna show you
oh some little rich [ __ ] in a dance oh
no sometimes it's other semi-trucks
damn lexus yeah whatever and it gets
kind of scary sometimes and
oh it's other semis yeah it's cars as
well semi trucks
it's not like it used to be so the
because when i was growing up i always
felt like there was a strong sense of
camaraderie you know i grew up
in my neighborhood everybody had like a
uh a ham radio you know or a tran what
is it
called cb like a cb radio yeah
date men that had cbs and so we always
had seabees around everybody in our
neighborhood had a cb in their car
yeah so sometimes if you weren't doing
anything you just go sit in your car
and just talk to people going by on the
interstate uh it's not like it no more
and you would see it would seem like
there was a lot of camaraderie between
the truckers out there it's
it's not you could know you could
actually be coming up on traffic it's
stopping
by bumper to bumper all you see is brake
lights
and you'll get on the radio and be like
hey has anybody got the ears on let me
know what's going
on up there well can't you read the
goddamn sign it was only about 10 miles
back
and it's like shut the [ __ ] up
i just asked a simple question you you
know and yeah it starts getting heated
really yeah yeah and i told jeffrey i
said my son
i got the benefit you know it's like you
i've been in the truck before and
honestly be holding the steering wheel
at the power and turn it off oh you can
shut it down
have to listen to you [ __ ] i'm turning
this thing off you know
and it's it's the people are rude you
know just
rude so there's not a sense of
camaraderie there's not as much of a
sense it's almost cut throat
anymore and i didn't see that when i was
a kid when my dad was driving
because back then we were allow his kids
me and my two brothers
we would climb in the back seat of the
or the back bed of the pickup truck
ride down i-65 to dean's lake in indiana
go swimming and stuff and get back in
this you know the pickup and
ride back you know do all this to all
these trucks you know hey
it was part of life yeah you don't
hardly see that anymore
and then people cutting you off all the
time but no
you got to think of it my teacher told
me this when i was in school
every vehicle whether it's a semi a car
motorcycle whatever picture little kids
in it
so that that gets drilled in your head
like it's almost like a mental pitcher
you have right off the bat
but if them little kids [ __ ] up
there on their kids oh yeah
i've seen them you know you know and and
like pick their nose throw boogers at
you know dude it can be mean but most of
the time the little kids are just got
the little fists going
you know and they're just laying on i've
scared the [ __ ] out of bus drivers
oh yeah that's fun it is yeah what kind
of bus are you talking are we talking
greyhound are we talking
school bus oh yeah anybody could do with
little kids you got
a whole row of little kids all grinning
at you staring out the window
you're riding right alongside of them
you know and you're a woman too so
little kids you know
kind of just little little more yeah and
i'm just
giving that horn hell you know
entertaining them and the whole time the
bus driver's like
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i was like oh sorry sorry you know going
past her waving
and then finally she right up alongside
of you she toot her horn oh yeah yeah
yeah the kids are having a ball so good
evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one ah